aquí tengo una serie infinita expresada
en notación sigma y te invito a que
pausa el vídeo ip así puedes encontrar
el resultado de esta serie que tenemos
aquí la cual se va a evaluar a un número
entonces suponiendo que estuviste
pensando en eso trabajemos juntos lo que
tenemos aquí es una suma desde acá igual
a 1 hasta 550 de 2,50 y siempre que
intento evaluar una serie me gusta
expandir un poco la suma para tener una
idea de cómo se ve así que veamos si yo
empiezo con camps igual a 1 que me va a
quedar
bueno pues obtendría 2 que multiplica a
1 más 50 y si acá vale 2
bueno pues obtengo 2 que multiplica a 2
más 50 y que pasa cuando acá vale 3
bueno pues tengo 2 que multiplica a 3
más 50 y bueno así me puedo mantener y
mantener y mantener y mantener evaluando
términos hasta llegar al último término
que es cuando camps toma el valor de 550
cuando k toma el valor de 550 que me
queda bueno me queda dos veces
dos veces 550 550 más 50 estás de
acuerdo entonces veamos de esta primera
parte de esta primera parte que obtengo
bueno 2 por 1 es 2 más 50 me quedan 52
estás de acuerdo más y después si evaluó
este segundo término que me va a quedar
de esto dos por dos es cuatro más 50 54
más aquí
20 36 50 56 y así no voy a mantener
sumando y sumando y sumando hasta llegar
al último término que me queda 2 por 550
lo cual es 1.000 1.100 más 50 sería 1150
entonces esto nos da una buena idea de
cómo es esta suma porque vamos a empezar
en 52 y después vamos a seguir sumando 2
a cada término sucesivo hasta llegar a
1150 y después vamos a hacer la suma de
todos
y como cada término sucesivo aumenta en
la misma cantidad aumenta en dos de aquí
a acá aumentas en dos y así te mantienes
entonces podemos reconocer a esto como
una serie aritmética esto porque cada
vez aumentamos la misma cantidad y la
buena noticia es que existe una fórmula
para la suma de series aritméticas
entonces lo primero que vamos a hacer es
aplicar la fórmula pero después vamos a
seguir con un poco de intuición para ver
el por qué funciona esta fórmula y de
hecho en otros vídeos hemos comprobado
esta fórmula pero siempre es bueno tener
una idea de cómo funciona porque
recuerda esta fórmula no surge de la
nada entonces la fórmula para la suma de
series aritméticas es la siguiente la
suma de los primeros en términos de una
serie de temática va a ser igual al
primer término al primer término
último término más el último término
esto entre dos y bueno date cuenta que
esto esencialmente es tomarme la media
aritmética la media aritmética del
primer término y el último término o
podemos decir que es el promedio en un
lenguaje día a día más común podemos
decir que es el promedio entre el primer
término y el último término y bueno a
esto lo voy a multiplicar a esto lo voy
a multiplicar por el número de términos
entonces si intentáramos aplicarlo a
este caso que tenemos aquí donde
buscamos obtener la suma de los primeros
550 términos entonces que me va a quedar
así que cambiemos de color bueno pues
entonces la suma de los primeros 550
términos de bueno esta expresión que
tengo aquí va a ser igual al primer
término que quedamos que 52 52
más el último término que quedamos que
es 1150 la suma de estos dos va a ser
dividido entre 2 recuerda es el promedio
ya esto habrá que multiplicarlo por la
cantidad de términos que tenemos lo cual
sabemos que son 550 550 muy bien habrá
que multiplicarlo por 550 así que vamos
a hacerlo si sumo 52 más 1150 esto es lo
mismo que 1200 dos vamos a rectificar lo
250 más 50 100 mil 202 ok esto dividido
entre dos ya esto habrá que
multiplicarlo por 550 muy bien cuánto va
a ser esto
ok 1.202 entre 2 estos 601
550 así que lo voy a hacer por aquí a
550 si esto lo multiplicó por 601 que
voy a obtener bueno 1 por 550 es 550
después voy a poner un cero aquí en las
unidades y voy a multiplicar este por
todo esto pero bueno son por ceros 000 y
después voy a poner un cero las unidades
un cero en las decenas y vamos con las
centenas para multiplicar las centenas
tengo que hacer la multiplicación de
seis por 550 6 por 0 0 6 por 5 es 30 así
que voy a poner un ser aquí y 3 aquí 6
por 5 es 30 333 33 ok así que voy a
sumar todo esto y voy a obtener mi
resultado esto es 0 por aquí va un 5 por
aquí a otros 5 después sigue un 0 y
después un 3 y otro 3 es decir que mi
respuesta es 330 1550
esta suma es igual a 330 1550 ahora bien
dije que con un poco de intuición vamos
a ver por quién utilizamos esta fórmula
y para eso me voy a tomar de nuevo y con
calma la suma de sus primeros 550
términos para ver si llegamos al mismo
resultado voy a cambiar los colores de
nuevo y ahora voy a escribirlo de la
siguiente manera para eso déjame bajar
un poco la pantalla y vamos a ver lo de
la siguiente manera me quiero tomar la
suma la suma de los primeros 550
términos de la expresión que teníamos
arriba pero sabíamos cuántos esto esto
es lo mismo que 52 más 54 más 56
y así me mantenía sumando y sumando
sumando hasta llegar al último término
el cual si recuerdas eran 1150 muy bien
ahora me voy a tomar la misma suma de
los primeros 550 términos la voy a notar
justo aquí acá abajo la suma de los
primeros 550 términos pero esta vez la
voy a acomodar de una manera distinta
voy a empezar con el último término y
después voy a ir sumando todos los
términos anteriores hasta llegar al
primero es decir el último término es
1150 estás de acuerdo y quién va a ser
nuestro penúltimo término bueno nuestro
penúltimo término es 1150 menos 2 lo
cual 2.148
ok y nuestro antepenúltimo termino bueno
ese es 1.148 -2 lo cual es 1.146 estás
de acuerdo y después no voy a mantener
sumando y sumando y sumando hasta llegar
al primer término que sabemos que es 52
ok y porque estoy haciendo todo esto
bueno porque si ahora quiero sumar estos
dos renglones tanto esta parte derecha
como esta parte izquierda que voy a
obtener buenos y sumo la parte izquierda
de estas dos igualdades voy a obtener
dos veces la suma de los primeros 550
términos estás de acuerdo una suma más
otras sumas son dos veces esa suma y
esto va a ser igual a bueno observa si
yo sumo estos dos que voy a obtener si
los nuestros dos voy a obtener 52 más
202 estás de acuerdo y si a esto le sumó
la suma de estos dos que voy a obtener
bueno pues 54 mil 148 es 1200 2 y si a
esto le sumó la suma de estos dos que
voy a obtener
bueno pues 56 mil 146 es 1200 2 y creo
que este número te parece muy conocido
ahora estoy seguro que ya ves todo
claramente porque si yo me mantengo
sumando y sumando y sumando puedes
seguir obteniendo 1.202 y cuando me tomó
en la última suma que es la suma de
estos últimos dos términos que voy a
obtener bueno 1150 más 52 es mil 202
entonces cuántos 1.202 tengo bueno pues
esto va a ser igual a 550 por 1200 2
porque recuerda que tenemos 550 términos
es justo lo que dice aquí tenemos 550
veces
a 1.202 entonces esto es lo mismo que
550 por 1200 2 y entonces si quiere
resolver esto para la suma simplemente
tienes que dividir todo esto entre 2
todo esto entre 2 que es lo mismo que
todo esto entre 2 y bueno este y este se
cancelan y ahora si me queda una
expresión para la suma la cual es 550
por 1200 dos entre dos que estoy seguro
que ya lo habíamos visto es exactamente
lo que obtuvimos aquí arriba en fin
espero que todo esto te haya dado la
intuición de cómo se obtiene esta suma